welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season two finally arrives
this week bringing us full circle with
Marvel's greatest storyline since
Avengers end game one driven by
perplexing Mysteries dense World
building and a horny clock I said clock
as we Embark upon the season 2 premiere
we wanted to refresh you with the 10
most important questions to keep in mind
as we work our way through this second
season I have spent the past two years
in change on new rockstars keeping that
candle lit keeping mentally fit
analyzing every bit of footage that I
could brushing up on the history of 19th
century America and narrative time
travel fiction All to make myself ready
for when the show came back and here I
am it's looktober or clocktober I said
clock October let's do this question one
what is Ms minutes I have a suspicion
that Miss minutes is gonna be the
breakout character of season two I think
it's interesting that it is Miss minutes
in my SS minutes not miss minutes it is
a more Antiquated Miss minutes she is
available friends no ring on that finger
and I think that's actually pretty
important for how we should see this
thing we know from season one that she's
not a recording she's not alive she's
sort of both and she's not a hologram
being projected from any visible light
source she can interact with the
physical world and while she serves the
TVA and serves TV remains in his agenda
she is okay keeping secrets from
rensslayer which tells us that he
remains had two female confidants which
could make things interesting I
speculated in the video last August that
Miss minutes is actually made up of
temporal radiation stemming from Victor
timely presenting to the World's Fair
attendees a new way to derive energy
from Time trailer footage shows a
monochrome ghostly form of her
terrorizing those World's Fair attendees
so just keep an eye on Miss minutes this
season how much she knows how far her
powers go and who she is ultimately most
loyal to alright question two what
change in the TBA to make he remains
hide himself and invent the timekeepers
because season one ends with Loki in an
earlier era of the TBA when he remains
did not hide himself from TDA employees
and kept statues of himself with his
face out in the open in the season 2
trailer footage Loki prunes back a mural
wall of the timekeepers to show that in
that previous era that wall had big he
remains faces and at some time between
then and now he wallpapered over himself
so something must have changed between
then and now to make he remains want to
erase his employees Minds to compose
this new script from the TBA narrative
commission presented by the animated Ms
minutes crediting the timekeepers and
let everyone think it was the
timekeepers running the show maybe this
is his attempt to hide from Ren Slayer
or hide from his other variants to use
the TBA as a kind of shell company or a
front without his enemies associating
the organization with him all right
question three what is rensslayer's
history and relationship with he remains
season 1 ended with Rensselaer leaving
the TVA through a Time door in search of
free will we learned that she was once a
high school principal and frankly D
Roosevelt High School in Fremont Ohio in
2018 and the comics princess ravona
rensslayer was King the conqueror's
overquitted love interests back in
Avengers 23 back in 1963 which season
one referenced by making rensslayer's
old Hunter ID a23 season 2 footage shows
her in Victorian era Garb at the 1893
Chicago World's Fair in the vicinity of
Victor timely I've speculated that she
could have been that fourth broken time
keeper statue in the Citadel Lobby that
perhaps he who remains in Rensselaer
might have both ruled over the TVA
together at some point all right
question four is the TVA on its own
timeline axis this I think is going to
be an extremely important question as we
watch season two because throughout
season one we assumed that the TBA was
removed from time in a kind of Dimension
unaffected by the flow of any other
timeline as in the comics the TBA exists
in the null time zone in Mobius since
season one told Loki that quote time
works differently in the TVA but in
season two we know from Trailer footage
that Loki has begun time slipping the
show's term while he is inside of the
TVA time slipping is a whole new rule
that this new season seems to be
establishing to be clear Loki is not
glitching laterally through different
dimensions and universes like miles
moraleses and the spider-verse movies
Loki is kind of like skipping forward in
time and hopping backward in time but
along the same timeline a timeline that
flows through the TV a meaning that the
TVA must exist along its own axis its
own flow of time where cause and effect
exist and Lasting changes can be made to
the TVA on that axis and history can
take its own course on that axis so as
we watch through these season two
episodes how exactly that works it's
going to be a new question that we just
really have to keep in mind all right
question five how did the TVA begin the
origins of the TBA seem to be another
point of focus for season two because
based on trailer footage of the king
variants Victor timely we see shots of
him with his temporal Marvel at the
World's Fair and a quick glimpse of him
inside of the TVA if you look closely at
the background I think Victor timely
must have been part of the origins of
the TBA like he's got some original
blueprint that they need to fix that
temporal Loom inside of the core of the
DBA I speculated back in July the Victor
timely and he remains might even be the
same variant all right question six what
were the direct consequences of Sylvie
breaking the sacred timelines yeah this
is going to be the most immediate
question I assume that season two is
going to deal with remember after season
one came out every MCU title that
touched on the Multiverse like what if
no way home Multiverse Madness Mania and
even before it one division we totally
speculated might have been connected to
that moment Sylvie killed he remains but
only season two of Loki is actually
responsible for giving us real answers
to what happened and what was affected
by that decision it seems like that
decision is what has led the temporal
core getting overloaded like this what
led to Loki's time slipping and led to
Sylvie to start working at a McDonald's
in the year 1982. now long time new
Rockstar's viewers know how much we use
geology and how long we've been using it
for but if this is your first time
hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't don't know
where to start geology can create a
simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine for you all you gotta do is
take a quick 30 second quiz right now if
you use the code new rockstars 100
geology will give you 100 off their
award-winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30 off one skin hair or body products
when you add it to your trial it's truly
a while to offer one of the best they've
ever given our audience so click the
link in the description or go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started alright
question seven what is he who remains
connection to Victor timely and the
other Kang variants basically how are
all the members of the Kang Dynasty
connected and how much do they know
about each other in the season one
finale he remains made it clear that he
knows who the other kings are that he is
the one who tamed Elias to prune the
others and end the multiversal war
that's why he's the one who remains but
we don't know if they know who he is
those other kings in the quantumania
post-credits scene knew who Kang the
exile aisle was in the quantum realm but
he remains entire existence maybe a
secret to everyone except Ms minutes and
Loki and Sylvie Victor timely might also
be in the blind a Kang unaware that he
is a Kang because otherwise I don't know
why they let him inside the TBA to help
them if he knew how powerful and evil he
could become all right question eight
what happened in the Citadel now I
mentioned the broken fourth timekeeper
statue in the city of the lobby which
was one of the big Mysteries left at the
end of season one but one new detail I
discovered in my deep dive of the entire
season back in February is that there is
actually an entire wing of the Citadel
that is caved in and barricaded when
they first enter and first talk to Miss
minutes some forbidden section that Loki
Sylvie or anyone could not access so
really The Citadel was built I think to
be shared by multiple rulers and now
that it's just he remains alone he's
kind of like a sad divorced citizen Kang
who hauls away in one part his man cave
of his vast Xanadu alright question nine
what happens to the void now when we
last visited the void it seemed like
Loki and Sylvia temporarily defeated or
at least stalled eliaith so not really
clear if the void continues to be
functional as a junkyard for pruned
people and things if it's garbage eater
is shut down there is a quick shot in
the season 2 trailer footage of a
Victorian dressed rinse layer in the
void so I assume that we're going to
revisit the void my theory has been the
void will become the future battle world
map for Secret Wars and based on set
photos for Deadpool 3 it looks like
Deadpool and Wolverine are gonna fight
in some part of the Void where there is
a pruned 20th Century Fox logo alright
finally question 10 is the MCU governed
by Branch timeline Theory or are all of
these branches part of a Vine that
snakes back on itself in a flat circle
this is perhaps the deepest and most
existential of all of these questions do
we have free will or not despite all the
talk about Branch timelines and Nexus
events if he remains is to be believed
from the season one finale no Marvel
characters do not have free will and
time is a flat circle I mean based on
the curvature of the Sacred timeline
orbiting around the Citadel at the end
of time it does seem like that is a ring
when Kang the Conqueror in quantumania
showed the time mind it was a ring that
snaked back on itself and the character
OB is short for Aura Boris a snake
eating its own tail he remains dies
because he set history in Motion in a
way that Sylvie would eventually kill
him he put her on that path Sylvie
didn't make that choice according to her
own free will she was destined to do it
the secret timeline started to Splinter
before she even stabbed him she was
destined to do it the threshold moment I
dove into in my deep dive video that was
when it started to happen he remained
script and everything is also what Iman
villani confirmed to me for Kamala Khan
going back in time when I interviewed
her back in July 2022. I think we're
gonna see other ways in which nature and
the architecture and the causal events
inside of the TVA end up getting
dictated by upcoming Decisions by
characters things are the way they are
because they've always been that way and
you are destined to make decisions that
set that past in the stone so
programming note here's how you can
watch new Rockstar's Loki coverage
throughout October you will be able to
see our in-depth Easter egg breakdowns
every Thursday evening I'm gonna go
crazy on the series it's like I was made
with this it's gonna be right here on
the new rockstars Channel season two
mere breakdown coming this Thursday
after the episode drops October 5th also
each of our Loki reactions and after
shows inside Marvel are going to be
every Thursday evening on the break room
Channel dropping just before our Easter
egg breakdowns come out on the main
Channel inside Marvel's going to feature
me Tommy bechtold mod Garrett and maybe
some other guests so be sure to tune in
also we're going to launch a new week
weekly format here on the main new
rockstars Channel every Sunday sneak
peeks a q a show in which I will look
ahead the upcoming week of nerdy news
joining me for the sneak peek in between
episodes of Loki is going to be our good
friend Jessica Clemens now we're also
going to be finishing up our Loki season
one re-watch episode 5 journey into
mystery coming this Thursday midday
before the season 2 premiere drops our
season one finale re-breakdown will come
sometime between episode 1 and episode 2
of season two and as always we're gonna
make other Loki videos to answer your
big questions as they come up my goal
this season is to be your YouTube
companion to help you with what you are
most curious about and to take my cues
from where the show seems to be leading
us and to invite you in on the crackpot
Theory crafting for you to indulge in it
if you like but not hold it against you
if you think I'm reaching please support
all three channels in the new rockstars
Network and support us by grabbing some
merch over at nerd riot.shop you can
follow me at eavos following rockstars
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time bye
[Music]
thank you